la llegada de Gustavo Méndez a Nueva
York fue hospiciada por un político
republicano uno de los gobernadores de
los estados del sur le compró un billete
de bus que lo llevó al este a la ciudad
que se ha convertido en uno de los
núcleos de la migración latinoamericana
a Estados Unidos
la selva o aparte de la selva de
enfrentarse a los demás países
las limitaciones que te ponen que
tuvimos en Nicaragua que tuvimos en
Honduras en Guatemala
la historia de Gustavo es similar a la
de más de 17.000 personas que han
llegado en los últimos seis meses a
Nueva York provenientes especialmente de
países centroamericanos y de Venezuela
su vida en una crisis migratoria la urbe
se enfrenta a la amenaza de desbordar su
sistema de Refugio
antes de este gran aumento de
solicitantes de asilo solía haber un
periodo de esperar de entre ocho meses y
dos años preveo que con la mayor llegada
de solicitantes de asilo al menos se
doblará
la ciudad liderada por el demócrata Eric
Adams tuvo que anunciar el estado de
emergencia en octubre
y el domingo la oficina de presupuesto
independiente de Nueva York aseguró que
sus gastos anuales para brindar Refugio
educación y atención médica a los
solicitantes de asilo se estiman en 600
millones de dólares unas cifras que
según el informe no estaban
presupuestadas previamente y que
necesitarían de mayores recursos
federales y estatales para poder
enfrentar la masiva migración